there is no minimalist rulebook well
until now the minimalists have created
sixteen rules for living with less a
free ebook which you can download right
now and the minimalists com /resources
enjoy do you think once we as society
get to a new normal
well people go back to their
consumeristic lifestyles or do you
believe society has learned from this
pandemic and will scale their lives back
to more minimalistic dude I just saw a
stat today consumer debt is up 14 it's
like fourteen point three trillion
dollars now yeah like it is so I don't
know if that does that include just 2019
like I didn't I'd have to look I don't
have a chance to read the article but
consumer debt is still growing without a
doubt it's gonna grow even more now but
but let's talk about why income is down
substantially yeah yeah and so if income
is down some people are right now having
to we're very fortunate right there's
there's what I would call rich Co vid
and Porco vid yeah at this point and
right now you and I aren't actually
wealthy but we're we're relative to you
know like my brother who lost his job
for a while and his wife lost her job
which is was even more devastating cuz
he was able to go get a job at Amazon
and and but his wife doesn't have job so
they're no longer a two-income family
right so when you cut a family family's
income and half or less in half or
whatever you might take on some debt
yeah and and were you or you might feel
like you have to take on some debt you
you you you you may not actually have to
take it on in fact I was talking to our
publisher yesterday we had a we had a
really good call about the the second
draft of love people use things and and
I was they made some recommendations
some changes and I agreed by and large
with most of them and then we got to the
money chapter and they're like well you
have to put in there that you know some
people can't all get all the debt I'm
like no I'm not gonna put that in there
I I don't agree with what you're saying
you're wrong that some people can't get
out of debt yeah I'm like oh you're
wrong oh yeah and a long
time line anyone can get out of that
right I mean and so it is there is there
are there seventeen Americans somewhere
who make minimum wage and have $700,000
in debt yeah maybe
okay but it's fine even and I'm not an
advocate of bankruptcy but even there
like there was some predatory going on
maybe bankruptcy does make the most
sense there but even if you have if
you're like me and you had about half a
million dollars worth of debt like I did
in my late 20s
it took took a lot of effort it took
four years of not misery not misery but
of extreme discomfort yeah it's a lot of
discipline a lot of self-discipline yeah
yeah and selling a house that was
oversized and right using that money to
pay off debt etc selling cars etc etc
etc but anyway there may be times where
people are taking on debt now because
they feel like they have to you don't
necessarily have to and and we often
call minimalism living within your means
ISM if that's the more practical title
for people right then then I thought I
would think about it that way and so
yeah debt is another bad habit that
people might pick up so it's answer your
question Tyler yes and yes do when
people go back to consumeristic
lifestyles yes some people will well
some people come out of this pandemic
being more minimalist yes oh yeah and
it's up to you to decide which half you
fall into